the truth is that government is a
faith-based
system and that's that's especially true
for democracy the whole thing is kind of
ryant on this it's all a religion in a
way like it's all like you believe in it
we believe in look government is a
religion in in every sense of the word
right you it has its kind of like um
sacraments and its rituals and its
nobilities and it's sacred cows it has
blasphemy the things you're not allowed
to say right it has all of this and also
you know much like religion um and I I
say this as someone who believes in God
so don't take this the wrong way but it
is so picture this like the religion you
don't believe in not the religion you do
believe in okay so if you're religious
every other religion not your one uh but
also it doesn't exist like government
itself doesn't exist it's an idea that's
in your head and that idea is almost
gone well right